いらっしゃいませはじめしゃちょーです
皆さんは私ははじみ社長のアルバイト時代
を
ご存知でしょうか
健介さん知ってますかはいあれ知ってるけ
よく言ってたじゃないですか
俺コンビニの時来たことある俺
店員さんのところないわうわうわそれは
語れません原付さんあの僕一応アルバイト
でコンビニ見てもらった通りわかると思う
んですけどもローソンさんローソンさんで
結構長い間働かせていただいてたんです
けども僕
社会出てないじゃないですか大学卒業して
そのままYouTuberになってしまっ
たのでその
社会人というか
雇用されて働くっていうその正社員みたい
な社会をあんまり学んでないようなね
みたいな見方してません視聴者の皆さん
違うんですよはっきり言って自分から僕は
社会性がありますとか社会知ってますとか
あんまり言えないんですけどもある程度の
常識とか働くってこういうことだよとか
始めたちょ1人の人間として育ててくれた
恩師の方が
実はコンビニにいらっしゃいましてまあ
世の中アルバイトを知ったことある人
知ってる人したことない人いろいろいると
思いますけれども僕は
正直アルバイトで動いたくさんのことを
学んでそれでまあ常識ないですけども何て
言うんでしょう社外で必要なことは学べた
のかなと思ってちょっとそんな僕を育てて
くれた方というかもう恩師の方に今日は
会いに行きたいと思いますじゃあ早速2個
と思います
[音楽]
いらっしゃいました
お願いします
お久しぶりですこんにちはこんにちは
僕の
恩師の
石塚さんです
美味しいって言ってくれるのにありがとう
自己紹介お願いしてもいいですか私石塚
直美と申します
静岡市内で
コンビニエンスストアの経営を
ちょこちょこやらせていただいてますで
そのあのあれですね
店舗
展開するし始めるかなーっていうこの
アルバイトに初めて来てくれた
僕が大学1年生の時ですね
初めてバイポ
アルバイトしたことなくて
ほんと大学1年生で初めてアルバイトする
なら
コンビニが
楽そうだなと思います正直
聞いてましたあ本当ですか
と思って応募したところ
石塚オーナーのコンビニローソンで
働くことになってそこからすごい
いい意味でちょっと思っていたコンビニと
は違ってたと言いますかなんかすごかった
ですよね
すごいですよねありがとうございます今も
そのすごいなーでやってるんですがでも
多分そこにあのー
[音楽]
江田君たちがいてくれてだからこそ今が
あるなっていうのを私自身も思ってます
みんなの協力がなかったら
きっとこうやって他店舗やってこともでき
なかったんだろうし
自分がこう目指してたものっていうのを
一緒にやってた
ぞっていうのがの時代はすごく大きかった
ですあんまり
僕がその
ローソンで働いていた時代のこと皆さん
知らないと思うので
オーナーさんぐらいなんですよいろいろ
知られてるのを
ちょっとねちょっといろいろ聞いてみたい
なと思っておりますよろしくお願いします
早速聞くんですけども
はじめしゃちょー
自宅の第一印象はどうでしたかはい
第一印象は全く残っておりません
というか
多分そのこう印象って
働いていく中でついてくるもんだと思うね
仕事していく中でなので最初はもう
やっぱりでも
静大生といえば
真面目で
絶対的なこう信頼と安心
静大生だったら間違いないぞでそれは
やっぱりこう過去の先輩たちのおかげだよ
ね
僕が働く前になさった
静大生の方たちがやっぱりそのきちんと
仕事してきてくれたっていうその信頼に
基づくもので
そこがすごい大きかったなと
でもちろんそのもう全く信頼を裏切らず
当時の写真を見るとですねだいたいああの
ギャルを
ギャルをみたいな感じだったんですがでも
もう全くこうあの
イメージと全然違って
本当にあの真面目できっちりどちらかと
いうと創作的にこういろんなこともやって
きてくれたっていう
でどちらかというと本当にみんなすごい
仲良くてねサークルのノリで
当時仲良かったんです花火とか行って
バイト終わりによく放課後やってたよねあ
そうです
仕事終わってあと
食べたり飲んだりよくその辺の話はこう
聞いてたんで
懐かしい
放課後やってたんじゃないかなと思います
か最初
[音楽]
ほんと使えなかったと思うんですよ
自分でもびっくりするくらい
足引っ張ってて
あんまりでもねそんな記憶がないんだよね
そういう記憶は
オーナーさんの
夜の時間帯だったんでオーナーさんが帰宅
された後にやらかしていや結構やらかした
んじゃん
それでもミックスにされてやっぱ
ダメなことはダメだって怒られ
修正トライアンドエラーを繰り返しだいぶ
ちょっとまともになっていったかなって
いう記憶はありますね
多分あんまりこうあんまりというか絶対
妥協しないでねって頼んでたところにで
たぶん先輩たちがこう後輩を教えてって
いうもう文化になってたとか
[音楽]
ねっていう中で
絶対妥協しないでねって言ってたのは
多分そのアジアスだったりとか
そういうところがあったと思うんだけど
多分そこは妥協しないでね
そうですね
声出すの恥ずかしかったねあそうなんだよ
でもセールストークはやれって言われるし
ねなんかその
他の一緒に働いてた方がめっちゃやってた
んで一緒にやりやすかったもんやっぱり
その環境とか風土っていうのは大事なのか
もしれないですね
[音楽]
ローソンって
すごく積極に力を入れていく時代だったと
かねでその中で
記憶に残ってるのは
本部が選ぶ優秀クルーさんか何か
確かまあそうでしたね
選ばれてでしかもそれ全国で何人かとかね
そうです
あれっていうのは
我々が推薦するんではなくその当時こう
チェックに来られて購入しましたその中で
選ばれたんであれは本物だったと思います
そういう
意味ですごい本物だったと思いますだから
すごくだんだんそういう意味で
成長が著しいなーっていうかもううちの
看板
娘じゃねえか看板息子とかっていう風に
なってなっててくれたんじゃないかなって
オーナーさんのお店はいいですかね
ローソンの
研修ビデオそうじゃないとねいただいたら
全国に流されてるんですよね
さっき
働いてた人が出てるみたいな
うちの普通日常あの日常を撮っていったの
がきとこ教育ビデオになっていうふうに
やりましょうそこがあってちょっとなんか
働いこのお店で働けてることになんかここ
に誇りというかそうなんですよなんか
すごい素敵な場所で高いレベルの
仕事の
内容というですクオリティ高いお仕事させ
てもらってるなって思ってそこも多分
続けれてた要因だったと思いますあなた
たちが作ってくれた仕組みをベースに今も
こうやっていけてるっていうのは
働いているうちに
みるみのオーダーさん店舗を増やしてて
知らないお店の名前があるみたいな
教育に行ってくれるみたいな会社を
言ってましたね
[音楽]
8店舗行ってたって俺
ローソンだけど
原付かな
でもそれはなんかこう
送信していや行きますよとかって
言ってくれて新しい店の新しいクルーズ
さんたちも一緒にやりながらねはいだから
もうその礎作ってくれたのは間違いなく君
たち世代ですありがとうございます
新しい店舗行くと
先輩顔でドヤ顔できたんで
楽しかったです
アルバイトの方入ってきて
せっかく教えたのにやっぱどんどん先輩に
なってくるわけじゃないですかあとから
入ってくる人も増えてなんかすぐ
色々教えたのにやめられるとショップです
ね
なんかうわせっかく教えたのにって
いう感覚はあっじゃあ逆にちょっとなんか
こう成長してくれるか教えた子
たちが嬉しいですね本当にとかやっぱやめ
なかったりずっとやってくれてるとあなん
か楽しくやってくれてるのかなって思って
楽しかったです本当に私も楽しかったです
よかった大学何もしてなくて
ただサークルサークルとかカッパツだっ
たらそんなに
シフト入れなかったと思うんですけど
ね
やることなかったからこそあれだけ
アルバイトに一生懸命
慣れたのかなと思います
見てる人気になると思うんですけど
ズバリ
コンビニのアルバイトのおすすめポイント
私は
[音楽]
いろいろやることが忙しいんで
逆にね
逆に取ればそのいろんなことを覚えられ
てるそしてまた今よく生産性とか言われる
けれどそれも身につくんじゃないかなと
たぶんきっと何かをしながら何かって
すごくやってたと思うね
それしかしてないんです多分
外形がどっちかというとサブの仕事で
もっと
他にやることいっぱいあったんですよ
マルチタスクでしたねだからそういうこと
をまあ知らないうちにもうなんか体で
動いてしまうとか
地球稼ぐだけじゃん
かなというのが一つとやっぱり
若い方だからお子さんからお年寄りまで
そしてまた男女問わずそして今は
国籍も問わずでどんな職業の方も訪れるの
か
ね誰にも行きますもんねなのでそういう
意味でこうあのどんな世代にもどんな
ジャンルにも対応ができる力が作ります
あとはまああの人間観察もいろいろした
から今の仕事に生きてるんじゃないいや
あります多分アンチってわかります
ネットで
悪口言ってくる人とかいるんですよそう
いうのアンチってんですけど
コンビニに働いているといろんなお客様来
られるわけですしなんか向こうがお客さん
の機嫌悪いのかわかんないですけど
めっちゃ怒られたことあるこんな何にも
悪いことじゃないあんた何なのそれみたい
なその接客なのにお弁当熱すぎるんだけど
最初はそれ結構
悲しく買ったんですけどそういうの
乗り越えて
怒られ慣れたというかでも褒めてくれた
ことだから
はいなんか
素敵な意見を取り込んで
自分にプラスにならない意見はもう
みんなにわけじゃないですけど
みんなせるように
なったの多分アンチに強くなったのは
コンビニバイトのおかげ説はあります
でも3年間もやると
後半ベテラン
ベテランで言われる方だったじゃないです
か
きゅうり上がって嬉しかったです
独自のその時給がアップする仕組みみたい
なのがあったのでじゃあ逆にちょっと聞い
てみたいのはああいう仕組みがあった方が
こうやりがいになるのがいやーやっぱり
もちろん
給料以外にも
救出したいんですけども
そりゃそうだよね評価されたなって思う
思いますなんか仕事量がやっぱできる仕事
量が増えたり
能力上がったなって思ってそれに伴って
給料上がると
嬉しかったですよ
優秀クルーションをとってくれるようなね
いやいやサンタさん
よかったんでね
ローソンで働けてないと
割ともっと炎上してたと思います
わしもそう思う
んで
金外すところはしっかり外しつつ閉める
ところを閉めて
抜けてるのは本当僕オーナーさんのおかげ
だと思っています
そういう要素がたくさん
本当にきちっと仕事をしてくれるなんて
なんかあのちょっとちらっと見た写真
みたいにあのどっかの前でこうこんな
なんかこうやっての写真撮ってるのがあっ
たりとかねそういうこうなんてかこうあの
2つ
金備えたところがあるからこそ今のこう
はじめしゃちょーっていうのがあるんじゃ
ないよくねなんだ私やYouTuberね
知らなかったんでね
働いてる時から僕YouTubeやってた
よねなんでバレたんでしたっけなんか突然
の動画って言われたそうだった
私は直美社長だとかって言ってたよね
卒業生が出てくれてそれ私も最高に
ラッキーでしただって
当時もうYouTuberとか言われても
わけわかんないですもんね
意味不明とかだって
YouTube動画あげる人たち本当にで
あの気持ち悪いことしかしなかったです
けどね気持ち悪いことばっかりやってたら
この子は大丈夫かなと思いますありがとう
ございました
何でしょう
教えてくれる人とかこう注意してくれる人
ってすごい貴重だと思ってますねじゃあ
これからもビシバシ行きます
何もわからなかった
ポンコツだった僕ほんと育てでいただいた
音声だと思っておりますのでありがとう
ございます
よろしくお願いしますこちらこそ
ありがとうございました
お先に失礼いたします
失礼いたします
はいというわけでどうでした
いいバイト先だったっていう本当
アルバイトでもほんと素敵な出会いがあっ
てこうして今始め社長がいるんだなと思い
ましたで本当にオチの方なのであの感謝の
気持ちを動画でも伝えられて良かったです
はいというわけでさっきオーナーさんとも
話なんですけども時給アップについてはね
バイトルさんも現在取り組んでるらしい
ですそんなバイトルさんとですね以前にも
時給アップ企業応援団として一緒にお仕事
させていただいたんですけれども今回は
なんと2022年10月の22日の土曜日
に新宿三角広場にて学生向けのバイトル
学園祭が実施されまーす
学園制だーそして私
社長や人気クリエイターを出演してみんな
で一緒に学園祭を盛り上げていきます
学生じゃないので来れません
動物園へ行ってください
応募方法なんですけどもバイトルのアプリ
をダウンロードそしてバイトルが現在の
直接ページがありますのでそこで必要項目
を記載するだけで応募可能です皆さん是非
応募してみてください詳しくは動画の概要
欄からチェックしてみてください
今この中で学生さん本当にイベントとか
たくさん亡くなってると思うんですけれど
もその思い出作りとして開催されるので皆
さんぜひ応募して一緒に楽しみましょうで
はバイトル確定祭でお待ちしております
じゃあな
[音楽]